here's a peek at what guests had to say
after the show okay Jeremy what do you
believe would happen to glenn greenwald
if he would return to the u.s. well i
mean what we've seen over the past two
weeks is an escalation of the threats
against gland and Laura Poitras I mean
you have James clapper the Director of
National Intelligence calling them
accomplices to a crime you have Mike
Rogers who's the chair of the House
Intelligence Committee basically
accusing Glenn Greenwald of selling
stolen documents and the fact that Glenn
has lawyers and they have asked for
assurances that he's not under some kind
of an indictment and the just Department
refuses to get that I I think it's
possible that they would arrest him and
either try to get him to testify against
Snowden or hold him criminally lot
criminally liable for the publication of
the documents I think I heard james
Woolsey what's it say Snowden should be
hung oh yeah I mean there's the the sort
of pitchforks are out and the posse is
coming it's just that they have to get
into Putin's Russia to get him right
good luck with that
right but I'm guessing he's not you know
how great can life be there and you know
I think I think he was in Hawaii with a
stripper girlfriend and you love that
stripper girlfriend story well I'm just
no I'm just saying you know it's good I
mean he's not easy to stuff a potato
into a g-string right you know I mean I
is it something like you ought to know
kind of thing
[Applause]
this is very unbell mara like I'm used
to seeing you know yeah yeah shut up
okay he's right I mean your point that
it's a different vibe in Russia right is
that gonna get in his head after a while
yeah no I mean I don't think he's living
comfortably there at all and the
question is gonna be whether he comes
back to face trial in which case every
lawyer in the country would want to
represent him and it would be an epic
trial given that yet everyone now knows
that there definitely were abuses
revealed because of his actions Eric
Holder says we won't give him the death
penalty he's probably facing life in
prison if they if they convict him here
and so his choice is either stay in
Moscow and have a life or come back to
the US and face life in a jail cell okay
bill nye how can we get more students
interested in STEM careers stem is
science technology engineering and math
it's all one word anymore Wow invest in
space exploration sake career invest in
space exploration and invest in
infrastructure its base exploration yeah
because that'll get people interested
that fires the imagination fires the
imagination the to deep questions where
did we come from and are we alone
everybody's ask those questions
including those people that I debated or
was around in Kentucky and when we when
you want to answer those that they're
trying to answer the same question where
do we come from
I mean I'm Lesley Bell there really
there's a book that documents back and
you guys seem to be of a certain age
back when the United States which is
still the world's largest space agency
has the world's largest bases or was
investing in beating the Rooskies to the
moon right there was just this
expectation that the future would be
better and everything would be great and
people were optimistic about the future
but and that's the nature of space
exploration but Bill don't you think we
don't know enough to really do exploit
the space exploration right I mean we
can't really even get to Mars we Mars is
hard man but Mars is relatively close so
we can get to Mars if we if I can use
the old expression threw money at the
problem
thrown over what about when we got there
we might find evidence of life if I'm
even talking fossil bacteria you guys if
we found evidence of life on Mars it
would utterly dare I say it change the
world no why would it change the world
okay Han sound bacteria first of all we
know what Mars surface looks like
there's obviously no life there that we
could learn places that are safe to land
on a budget we know that so what if
there's bacteria on Mars this well does
such a nerd would high-five at this base
and then and then nothing would change
nothing would you say student from the
hip it might change might revolutionize
medicine really how I don't know does it
affect your life - no the world is round
does it affect your life - no the earth
goes around the Sun and so the other way
around no yes yes it does you use your
cell phone I will say one exciting thing
I see because I teach a lot of college
students and why you in other places is
the young students are trying to solve
the problems of this planet and that's a
pretty exciting thing there is a boom in
the environmental sciences right now
we're investing money at the federal
level there's one thing the Obama
administration has been supportive of
now there are a lot of people attacking
him for that and there's another party
that's going to do everything possible
to try to eliminate funding for that
kind of research but right now it's an
area where we're primed to make real
advances and it's exciting to be on
college campuses and see students
enthusiasm for that you feel it and I
totally get this thing people are
calling millennial anger you heard this
expression no well young people come
growing up now people coming out of
college like what were you grown-ups
doing the last 40 years we got climate
change you're funding too many soybeans
and too much corn and not enough healthy
food - mimes point what were you what
were you guys doing we and they're angry
they're gonna clean up our mess yeah and
also one thing they were doing more than
the Millennials was voting I
that's who votes the lead maybe the
Millennials are rational cannot vote
maybe maybe the Millennials actually
have caught on to the fact that those
who couldn't control the nominating
process control the power since the
Nominating cynical is the domain of
about one or two percent of the
population and that the choices are so
preordained that there's a reason that's
the largest political party the answer
is don't just take your ball and know
that you know the answer the answer is
actually organized on a local level to
actually change the physical
infrastructure in your community to
change the food infrastructure in your
country that changed the infrastructure
the educational infrastructure and stop
wasting your energy getting sucked into
a vaporous lie that we call national
politics which can
[Applause]
the altar I just had the alternative is
local engagement around core resources
for you got a vote why I don't think you
do Wow voting is forcing my energy into
a lot of those people rather save my
energy for something that through fuel
which is housing your food fuel water
and education you know what your little
biosphere that you live in where you
don't have I don't live in a biosphere I
where I would I know I'm exaggerating
what I'm saying is eventually the people
who got elected who you didn't vote for
are gonna come and [ __ ] up your look it
doesn't matter because there's 196
people who provide 80% of the money for
the all the nominations of all of the
politicians and so when the choices that
I'm given are selected by 196 people who
have all of the money as to whether I
want to go with red or blue so basically
I'm sure I can choice one poisoned
hamburger or another poison hamburger so
you're like oh well this is a democracy
would you prefer to be poisoned by a
medium-well hamburger medium rare you
can't change by voting into a system
where the nominating process is rigged
by wealthy individuals thank rich
the world is a bad place Annalise a bad
place it's a waste of energy we both
would agree that once Adam committed the
sin and the girl that was it but but
given that system given that we live in
this fallen world
right you do have to make choices and it
and the world and the country is a lot
better because Obama as flawed as he is
is there instead of McCain and Mitt
Romney there are so many actually
different
I would say it's actually the banking is
identical the energy is identical the
military's identity energy I would say
not identical rate the rate of decline
may not be as fast in other words one
person is killing me with a fork the
other one would shoot me in the face
they're both killing me
I don't want any part of you no actually
I'd rather be stabbed with a fork okay
I'm shot in the head yes I would the
reason people still want to move to the
US and so very easy to be cynical I get
the nuts in a coin
I don't know I'm rational is because our
laws are a little better I'm not an
attorney all right but I've met them you
mean our laws our campaign finance laws
you referring that's exactly what I'm
talking no that's not what I'm talking
about you do most people have rights
most people it's a little better here
than a lot of places as screwed up as it
might be rap I'm staying out of this
only because I don't want to be the guy
arguing with Bill Nye arguing every kid
will demonstrate against me and no your
Real Time with Bill Maher ask villainous
guesses your questions right after the
show
at hbo.com or on Twitter